welcome to this video tal memorial round
eight the penultimate round it's um den
close to the end of the tournament and
it sir I think this is Gotham oftentimes
crunch time like them in other sports
where it gets to the last couple of
minutes and chest the last two or three
rounds count as we know if still from
the candidates tournament or we had one
of the most thrilling finishes in chess
history all right but back to the
current tournament this round saw gap
one of the actually the the modern
classic matchups cards and against
Nakamura but I get to that game Layton
let's serve look here first at Arnold
against kramnik in this tournament this
is a match above from the tail enders
actually as both on the current world
champion and his predecessor on yeah are
in really bad shape let's look at the
game got an Enzo surprisingly but island
place all kinds of openings displays
he's playing e4 mostly but once in a
while he plays default allows the limbs
oh we get Quincy to the classical line
and now Kramnik plays castles this is
also his main weapon here very often has
played to this variation in the last
couple of years and had made some
excellent contributions to theory here
but here the she played you for which is
some principle alternative it has been
this is a move that has been forgotten
for very long time but there has been
unearthed I
not 10 10 12 15 years ago until then has
some seen some popularity white gains
the center but he's not so well
developed this means that black
immediately gets some counter play and
the play gets very sharp now I 594
Bishop to d3 and c5 so black immediately
strikes in the center and white must be
young yeah alert to not overextend and
lose the center he is playing night at
three now black talk night takes and
Knight to d7 this is just one of many
lines that is serve that are possible
don't really want to make a theoretical
survey out of this white cable now I'm
covered the pot it was attacked by the
night Queen B 6 attacking this night it
retreated and now Queen to see sapne and
this is er a good move with the taxi
five of the text see for potentially
castles and now black took on e5 yet
fact after this capture only for black
wasn't an awkward pin here to go on c3
and f6 this is completely forced so we
can do a counting job its material
equality black has some targets but on
the other hand this is the pin that's
mentioned after rookie one it's
difficult for black to not loose upon
here so it took on c4 to Gandhi five and
we have some exchanges b6 so how to
assess this position it's materially
from material point of view it's equal
six is quite weak but if white will ever
manage to take the porn which in fact
happens in the game then we get a rather
drawn double rook endgame we see now
what I'm talking about Bishop d7 and
white increase the pressure here it
didn't really matter much he could have
taken instantly as well it leads to the
same thing at the end white one the
spawn but also exchanged night against
bishop and black always has the counter
play against those two pawns to a couple
of moves we got a completely dry fruit
and game which in fact after yeah after
this they agreed to draw it's not very
surprising result given that unloaded
kramnik on quite friendly terms and they
both on yeah they both probably want to
get this over with this terrible
tournament for both of them so unless
something extraordinary happens in the
opening it's not a very unlikely result
the straw all right let's go to the next
game and raking kayak in Russian duel
and we have the catch along here and
Reagan has varied his openings a lot the
Catalan is actually relatively easy to
prepare against kayaking because he
always places line the main line and
kayaking is an interesting idea it play
Queen c2 which is of course the main
continuation a six and now we played a
for this is one of two lines Quincy for
being the other one this is the more
technical line before it's a bit more
yeah blacking over TM double-edged is
really too much because it's still a
fairly positional affair strategical
affair
but its gathers this weakness is here
white is more trying to play with a
strong center and that's on a technical
basis this should be seven and now
Quincy forth quite normal but he played
95 which is the idea i mentioned quite
interesting trying to maybe take with
the night on c4 black instantly and
reacts to this 96 so that after night
see for black and simply capture here
and when a pawn for nothing this means
wife needs to react because d4 hangs and
you don't really want to do that because
if you look at this structure it looks
terribly weak but Dwight has weakened
his own King side as well and even if
white gets one or two points black has
excellent play in return after Queen c4
for example there's Queen d5 and now
white doesn't really want to take I mean
correcting stretching the pawn structure
but how where do you go if you don't
take it's quite difficult there's also
does those weaknesses IAM on the B file
this is what Andre can plate and this is
much better and I think it also leads to
a position well it seems that white is
quite comfortable probably not some some
some big big deal but i'd rather be
white here let's put it this way move do
you wanna quincy idea white can never
really win a pawn I mean it was possible
even a move before to take twice but you
really don't want to give up your
monster Bishop and get a mega porn for
it and give black this excellent piece
this is really a terrible idea to
the pole so after between c8 just 93 was
fine black took Queen tags and c5 okay
you don't want to have the palm back all
the time being a target for attack here
rather advances it Bishop to e3 would be
eight yeah and here I drank and played
before which was was not money was not a
bad move but White has on some other
ideas of course it's really a position
area why should try to do something i'll
try to play for bit of a nut and she
looks like you should have enough
pressure to at least one upon he won't
won he won won he won a pawn in the game
but down didn't really damn it it was
really enough to to really make a game
move out of this yeah Roxy one would be
interesting attacking c5 if black can
protects it as a 5 i'm not really sure
compared to the game of this is better
it's um certainly a better for Wyatt as
position but it's not so easy to
determine how much better it actually is
for example like this probably both the
rook don't know so this is this kind of
setup white is better because this is
just a weakness and this is also good
week but your pawns also not ideal they
they control many useful squares but
they are not so um so effective and no
in getting a passport at the end yeah
it's not so easy to determine the best
way to play what he played actually
wasn't bad as well before that's quite
an aggressive move and kayak and played
Bishop c6 immediately jettisoning
Paul that could have taken this is
actually interesting to look at after
takes takes there's some probably the
moon 85 and this is probably why
coyoacán didn't didn't play that black
is hard-pressed to move here cannot move
the bishop can gather you can move Ruby
atah which is completely useless cannot
move the people it's a quite a tricky
position if you look at this lie group
da dance for instance oops Bishop to b6
and after in exchange it's not so easy
to give like some advice what exactly
should you play ass black I can try to
get the King closer but even that
doesn't really solve your problems bla
black has some some chow I mean it's
probably not the end of the world but
you're defending he decided to play
Bishop to c6 and give away upon this in
this fashion after Bishop c5 we had the
trade b6 I think he had calculated
orders you're now in am in a pimp so
white must play Bishop to default Queen
to be seven check em three Luke see a
temple Queen lose b5 and my suspicion is
that kayak had had calculated this when
he played a bishop c6 here five or six
moves ago it's really not the difficult
line it's pretty much pretty much frost
okay all this is rather forced and here
it is quite evident that black with rook
c4 will get a good play against the B
phone the bishop is just rather passive
piece now and black may be active enough
to tie white down to the defense of this
before ponent further activity whoopsie
for Roxy
oxy 2 and so on so on Black has sub
compensation for the pawn not one
hundred percent sold that is enough but
it looks like it's probably enough take
stakes and queen d 3 plate no Luke c6
and tell you hear the computer actually
em gifts the next move as a mistake
which is probably true because this move
really makes it a draw a clear draw but
i'm not sure that the alternative is so
much better i mean it is better because
it's more complicated but probably it
ends in a draw as well the computer
gifts the exchange here and then we'll
see you on but i believe that this
actually yeah while it's not looking
very attractive if I I admit that
something like this is so just a
plausible line okay six something like
this is pour down but white will will
not win this especially as now the trade
is forced or bishops and this is here
it's just a dead position in a way that
what is ever going to win this if your
course you can try for ages but it will
be a draw but he should have tried that
it's not completely forced by the way
this end game that this is actually I'm
plate exactly like that but this is more
more testing Bishop c5 was played after
that black could take on c5 and here got
to the end game and this is dead now
this last last little trick now black
cannot take here with a check because
afternoon everyone there are two looks
hanging and there's always the spec rang
made so black loses the loop now of
course you just play drew gave aid and
not quite sure where exactly they agreed
the draw here here draw was agreed and
probably am white should indeed take on
set of Bishop c5 take here and try to
play this and game or maybe before I
mean white had a little something but it
probably never had any any serious
proportions so that black really needs
to worry to lose all right Gavin
Mammadyarov next game Gelfond leading
the tournament his best tournament ever
probably besides the the candidates from
yeah the candidates but this is
certainly is best tournament ever in the
round-robin format alright let's get
going girlfriend playing white against
Mammadyarov and we get the the Rogozin
defense of the Queens gambit this is
quite an interesting opening that I can
recommend William and I always had have
played it once in a while let's plug and
always thought all right you should
invest some time learn this and it's
probably a good defense I never really
got around to it but if you have some
time on your hands this is a very good
opening to to pair with the news oh
actually you start like this after Queen
season three you play the news oh and
after Knight f3 you can play the rogozin
and it's a bit similar because I you
have got Bishop before coming there are
some transpositions this is quite nice
because it combines a bit of the solid
fashion of the Queens gambit with some
activity it's not as yeah let's say
stodgy has some some mainline Queens
gambit declined
okay galfond play queen bee three which
is a relatively recent um move it has
been played even back in the 30s and 40s
but it came back into fashion a bit
after chrome leg plated um in fact here
I think miyano shows quite a good way to
play he plays c5 after the caption
nights is sick so he really am dozin
from full developing mode girl from
playing Bishop to g5 and now takes and
queen a5 the sir looks like a good
approach to me like tries to increase
the pressure along this diagonal and he
threatens to move the night to even put
more pressure on this piece will see one
played quite logical Bishop c5 and after
a three-wide were threatening before so
black plate Bishop d7 because before
isn't such a great idea we can look at
this wasn't played you played this one
but after before black actually can take
him the point is rook c8 and there's
simply too much going on here on c3 even
if white retreats this this is too much
it's really quite amazing how quickly a
white can go under him so but before
wasn't played of course girl from plate
III rook c8 and now we see that black
still has got counterplay ideas so wide
when for Queen B 5 which is of course
not the kind of move where you have
great ambitions but probably there
wasn't anything else just this one plate
and now
a couple of months later we had to some
more exchanges f6 this is important
black of course does not want to Castle
anymore if possibly Lizzie likes to keep
the king in the center on a seven for
example and then rip t8 and this is why
planes f6 to make room here for the King
would be eight and yeah this position is
very very dry and in fact after Bishop
853 h5 yeah small little trick trying to
trap the Bishop of Dwight is careful
yeah it's just a very equal position
white looks a bit more active with those
bishops maybe but there's nothing
substantial also here why it couldn't
really get anything by taking got this
here black cam can simply give away the
porn it's not a big deal can just play a
normal moves them let's say a five this
is just wrong it kills this bishop it
kills the night it can never go anywhere
and after some move I'm not sure what
why should play for argument's sake
let's let's say this one is probably not
especially great even then black can
even play g5 and this is excellent now
it's a pawn but those pieces are dead
really they don't do anything if you mix
the night let's say here there's this
move coming then this for example is
already winning for black okay
yeah and this shows that these pieces
are very unlucky we should be three will
win upon a piece so sorry not just the
porn it's the night yeah just the sample
online white shouldn't take on c6 played
just 91 593 tools to c5 is the idea yeah
white goes 95 now I can just take and
probably play this this is simple
exchanging this a couple of more moves
later here we had some sort of perpetual
with the or repetition with the bishops
and the drollest of wheat yeah I think
galfond certainly wouldn't have minded
to win the game but sometimes it just
does materialize and you simply should
go for the draw here white really has
nothing especially this Bishop is bad on
g3 you can just slowly maybe a buyer for
improve it but you certainly don't have
any hopes for an advantage so I'm not so
interesting draw but it happens what can
you do um let's go two more rows of each
karana now here we had the Scotch four
nights which moro had played earlier I'm
struggling to remember against whom
Kramnik i think it was chronic yes from
Nick and they made it wrong okay in the
Kramnik game he played Bishop g5 as much
I remember the classical would
he plays h3 this is kramnik smooth also
not novelty by kramnik last year but
sort of a rediscovery and get to me I'm
sorry to be a bit of a cynic here but
the whites hopes for an edge against v5
one in five I connected with move like
10 a tree in the Scotch four nights then
what really should play something else I
mean instead of one in four if you need
to go for that it's really a sorry state
but ok after d4 it's not much fun as
well try to get something against the
sloth ok c6 Queen a 3-wood late h3 is
just designed to make sure that nothing
is appearing on g4 the f3 square is good
for the Queen anyway and white sometimes
has this opportunity instead of going to
g5 or you can sometimes play this it's
basically not an entirely new set up
it's just mixing it in a bit and
delaying the Bishop g5 moves however in
this game now model plate Bishop g5 and
now we get to a very standard position
here black has various possibilities to
play he played age 6 which is the most
straightforward way to go about that and
now surprisingly i think Milosevic
exchanged on f6 this is a well-known end
game and it has the reputation of being
one of the driest lines in the whole of
chess which is certainly deserved it's a
very dull line and actually this is one
of the lines that I try to avoid this
black if I want to have an interesting
game simply because here white can
always play we can put this on the board
no I played rugby one here white can
always play something like this and
black has a hard time to not capture
this night at some point because
just so annoying and after the kept
capture this is a position where um gap
where white should draw against really
anybody I mean even I don't know an
expert player like 2100 should draw
against against Houdini here or cards
for that matter because it's just so
George very easy to draw okay but this
is what a moral plate but this is a line
to avoid this black if you want to win a
game against some decent player you
won't manage this end game is so dull
but of course why this must be very
unambitious to to go for that okay it
didn't happen it didn't happen he played
whoop do you want you should be 693 yeah
and 92 h5 this was mom's idea he
transferred the night to age 5 but black
can just use the bishop it's um it's two
bishops the bishop p.m. from B to
fianchetto funny enough always protect
the pawn this position is probably
around equal Roza which has some
concrete play here on the on the King
side we see that he's trying to to get
something here with rook to g3 and so on
intending this for example and he also
cut off the bishop so that the f6 pawn
must be covered from the side it still
should be around equal d 4 is a good
move of course but i wanna this helps to
get the bishop back into play or
establish upon yonder form white for for
instance could could play see for him to
make sure that the pawn doesn't appear
on d4 but this is a protected passer and
it controls III which is also a bit of
shame
this kind of move not in the near future
but it's always a week square here so
I'm after default white shouldn't play
c4 really hear me talk yeah Bishop to d7
and here just a second Bishop to d7 iro
create was played I actually had screwed
up my notes slightly after d4 there was
one line I needed to show and this is
the check and rookie want this is the
something to show what should black play
now play Bishop to e6 there are some
this coming and you really don't want to
lose a piece but here black can play
look to be six yeah at first it looks
like a blunder but in fact if you look
at this black has this very good
intermediate move attacking the rook
rook needs to move not quite sure
actually what the best square might be
yamu after the capture only black really
can play for win here with this central
pawns it's probably should probably
still a draw but this is nothing for
wide this is also why you took him and
after Bishop d7 gave the check yeah in
fact in the sole game that isn't
happening so much for quite a long time
exchange now yeah room 237 and now most
of it was trying to win upon you but
look at those pieces they're completely
misplaced on the edge from especially
this is a self pin so have good knife
when it already those here this is just
a nasty pin on the bishop so I'm I'm not
really sold on this idea it looks like
here it already looks like for me at
least that what is trying to lose the
game and not sorry that is a bad
expression not like he's trying to do it
on purpose but he tries to make
something happen and it may be it it's
more likely to backfire than to do him
anything good the couple of moves later
black had activated his bishops nicely
don't get this yeah here and now Caruana
played c4 which is a good roof really
little time on the clock morrow is down
to about one minute and what does white
play now in fact what what you do is
simply to capture after Luke to be eight
it looks quite scary at first because
this is really a very dangerous looking
check but after Knight f6 yeah the check
like and doesn't have anything better
than them probably a perpetual you can
try but it's also risky for black your
three points down so if you can give a
perpetual this is not too bad and kiss
is just always checking is a draw but
after see for morale down to one minute
now played the move g5 try to make some
use of this rook but this now just got
answered by c3 and hmm this is a very
hard one spawn and it's supported by two
bishops quite often despaired trouble
and in fact if you look at this a little
bit deeper you will see that this pawn
is promoting there is absolutely no way
to stop it after Nigeria technique this
was czech koruna simply could play c2
after the capture i played king two came
to d5 and down a bit irritated because
um
no as ICS got King be five I put the
game from the former website and this
said King I five and resins kingly five
actually also wins King d5 is just a bit
a bit better and he probably and he
probably played it um yeah the thing is
no way to stop the pawn absolutely no
way if white go see em there's rook c8
look at those pieces they are simply
dead not on the board yeah this yeah
yeah yeahs gives a new queen so frankly
it's just that one of those days with
the rotten tournament you just yeah hit
on some minds sometimes and this is this
allowing since upon to push forward is
simply a decision of a player was out of
shape in this event tomorrow now sharing
last place quite a quite a miserable
tournament alright so let's get to the
big one cars and a camera it's always
interesting to watch those to play
because they're both yeah such fighters
very rarely do you see an uneventful
draw and here cousin is some also really
forced to play for win let's see how it
was about his playing c4e six g3 so a
rather um strategical start let's say
going into something like the Catalan
but see success play this is interesting
after Knight f6 it's likely that we get
a Catalan or maybe already not sure
neither three and maybe deform or be 34
ready both interesting after you after
the semi but can also play this one okay
but c6 was played interesting this sum
is
a bit threatening to dig it's not a real
threat because very often you can
sacrifice the pawn but it's something to
worry about for white I have played this
position also quite the number of times
and I always I think if not sure don't
send me a game of mine from 15 years ago
where I didn't play that I usually just
played Knight f3 end and sacrifice this
like this and then continue to play an
in-game bed style but this is also quite
sharp and it's not like white is some
substantially better or anything it's
just my preference not to play what
cause of Lady Queen see to protecting it
I always wanted to yeah play Knight f3
and I didn't mind so much to sacrifice
upon queen city is to is perfectly
alright though Knight f6 93 and here
like I'm where I decided to take on sea
floor which is ok it transposase to a
line that is usually reach them by a
different move order but also this is
the line was with with a pretty solid
reputation so I'm nothing to to
criticize here Queen takes he didn't
need to he could have played Bishop d6
on 97 for instance son la camara plate
he takes e4 and now b5 Queens b3 yeah
that's also Quincy to I was almost
saying Quincy to because this is such
read routine move but queen bee three is
the more um testing move probably and
see Bishop e7 castles 97 and default so
we have a position on that is in fact
quite similar to catalan
and in some cases exactly this position
also may occur from a Catalan move order
queen bee three is the more interesting
with compared to Quincy too because now
the mix that black would like to play c5
to open up the bishop is hanging this
for now so this is a difference to
Quincy tool but the Queen Nazi to c5 is
just good this is why a six is played
here Binaca preparing this and causal
plays Knight to e5 very direct play
preventing c5 just by opening up the
diagonal plate Queen B 6 now you should
be three everything is directed against
the c5 push but at the end Black manages
to do that but now why it has an
interesting way forward he took and
played d5 yeah in fact um we already
have reached on a critical position in
this game rather early here on move 13
this is actually a position that has
been played before amongst others in a
game by one of the best German players
gil maya against you slap on my oven
dortmund 2011 and did this game put my
of took on d5 um with the pawn it's
really not much of a difference they had
this position to th then a form down
this I believe is the position where I'm
like is only marginally worse it's just
a bit worse not a dramatic problem but
he is a bit worse
um this is a weak point later this can
be a problem and those parts are
slightly weak they can be attacked
Knight c3 g4 for example put some
pressure here and in general Black has
slight coordination issues but it's not
a big deal in fact one of my of reach to
draw in this game however in this
position if black yeah if black doesn't
want to have this position what else
should he play like a more I in fact
played a move that is really am quite
surprising he played five and this is to
be honest really really bad I mean um
it's really also very hard to understand
why why you played this I mean okay in
the other move you you have zero winning
chances certainly oh not sure if you if
want to t somehow I have a hard time to
explain this book because it's really
terrible this year you need to use your
search for some explanation for this but
the idea I show you why this terrible
play day for no cars and this is really
just normal I mean everybody would play
this move intending night a 40 if this
pawn needs to move the bleep on then
Black is simply lost positionally and he
played before after a long thing of
course because it's like capitulation
but you had don't have ins what should
black play if you play I really don't
know what to put on the port let's say
the move like this okay
have a look at this this is the problem
at the end this is saying and it says
you just lose it I mean after this white
even has Queen a form this is probably
even better and this is basically
winning for what you have the APA file
it's all week you have the deep pawn
okay that's made on g2 need to be
cautious but this is just lost I mean
and not you don't need to be causin to
win it I'm very bad I really don't
understand what he what he was thinking
when he played in five I mean Nakamura
as a world-class player I didn't watch
the press conference I'm not sure if he
did explain afterwards what his
rationale was when he played in five
after a for the game is basically over
he needed to play before and this is
willing in a strategical sense for what
it's just so terrible problem is the
combination of pressure against t5g 65
and the deep on is too much white as
various ideas I can lecture let's say
castle look see one let's look at this
this is probably easier to to show what
is white writes a threat here besides
strengthening the position but let's say
it plays nothing move then this is
coming very basic threat on this also
winning needs to move
and wide wins it's just too much passion
he took on air for Carlin we captured
takes and now pawn takes the computer
actually lies likes the rook f form
which is not bad but this is just much
stronger look at this this is very
seldom that you see two pawns like that
just overwhelming for white Bishop a6
try to get something with the pin and
cars just remove the rock from the spin
King 2 h8 96 an additional problem yeah
Queen III was now played there was also
Queen g3 also quite good intending
Knight to f5 like this
just the the general idea something like
this it's very difficult for black 22 to
hold this is this idea in addition ecigs
f5 all kinds of the text ya in the game
Queenie III was played this is also fine
i mean it's more than one way for y2 to
continue yeah g5 was a bit of a
desperado move but understandable you
need to to unbalance somehow and in fact
I'm like a more ahead um had something a
couple of months later here actually
Carlton could have improved he played
King edge one but he could have played
Knight to f5 which was in fact even
stronger this strong because black
cannot take Queen g7 mate let's say
something like this and if it it's
really strong this was even stronger
than the game he played King edge one it
keeps a winning position it's not so
forceful and Bishop d3 may be trying to
protect here on f7 yeah in this position
here Carlton made a mistake played
rookies free which looks completely
normal but it's in fact a blunder you
should play Bishop h3 it seems intending
to to just take it and then play Queen
f6 which is strong but the problem is
not so much the positive sides of this
one but rocky 3 it's really a technical
problem here Nakamura I had had a good
chance to continue the game you like you
can look for yourself what should black
play now
okay putting on the board now you should
play work takes d5 this is actually
quite okay for black the issue is that i
got this is hanging so why it needs to
recapture and then Queen d6 and this is
in fact still a position that white
needs to win Black has some chances here
what do you play now probably this one
but after capturing now note that the
the queen is saying so the Queen iya
sayang so black needs to take let's do
this again look at five and then like
needs to take and our black Scott ideas
like c4 for example look here and it
gets tricky it's also somewhat better
for watching all this but it's much much
tougher than the game the game you
played Bishop g6 back and after look I
have one only then took here but then
after Luke takes Queen d6 Carlton had
the funny move rupee eight getting rid
of one rook queen is hanging so we had
this one coming yeah now finally move on
a camera this one simply because white
leads to take the Queen anyway so it
takes and King takes so the King has won
a bit of time to try to help defend and
now of course these six preventing King
is heavy yeah why does some
substantially better here but it's still
a bit of work carden could have made
life much easier for himself before
we're playing night f5 yeah this in fact
after here um nakamura played at five it
seems that Bishop takes v3 was a bit
tougher
it also seems to be a better for what
just like this here at the end does a
540 why this is probably winning this is
but this is a bit tougher though click
f5 and now the King also helped yeah he
gave away this pony was he fought to get
at least a better but only some precise
moves are needed to to win the game
right here nakamura resigned so very
tough course of events for Hikaru
Nakamura he played excellently was
leading the tournament and then lost two
in a row against galfond yesterday and
today against them Carlton and he's got
a really terrible score against cars not
quite sure it's like minus 10 or
something in classical chess he never
won a game which is really really not
great i mean is especially given the
style his risky start he should really
win the game somewhere but he never
manages he always loses or at best draws
so on what does this mean for the
tournament standing it meets that
Gelfond is leading alone before the last
round and cows miss the only one really
being able to catch him so how to point
behind and in the final round Townsend
is playing Musharraf with black and
galfond explain chronic with black so
they both have the same color and okay
very tough it's hard to imagine that
girlfriend would win with black but
chronic really is in bad shape maybe
Kramnik is just trying to make a draw
and get let's get it over with but he
hasn't won a game and yeah maybe he's
trying his best to to get
please get a win in don't know black
against mayara for cars and also isn't
exactly easy but yarrow can play rather
solidly if you want so um yeah
interesting let's see what happens maybe
Magnus can can do it again and catch the
leader last round but will be it will be
difficult thanks for watching I'll be
back tomorrow with final-round coverage